one of the top drivers in the Formula
one circuit mieze here with Aston Martin
Red Bull Racing who he represents good
to see you max for stopping good to see
you yeah good see you you bet so you're
in Southern California making your way
to Texas exactly okay quick pit stop
over here now that's how we call it no
but is that is that really part of your
vocabulary use words like pit stop and
sometimes yes what make sure you just
made a quick one right here we're gonna
redo the tires and then move on you are
22 years old your this is your 100th
Grand Prix Formula One Grand Prix you
have a certain amount of experience for
somebody your age how did you get
started in racing well my dad raised
himself and filmer one my mom raised
professionally in go-karting so
basically my my whole family was was
interesing already but of course when
you are very young the only thing I saw
really was was racing but brake I think
it's still you know it needs to come
from yourself so luckily I never had my
parents pushing me into the sport but it
was like me calling my dad for a go-cart
initially and that's how you start
driving and basically you do that from I
started when I was four and a half four
and a half yeah in a coke on I didn't
think you're a Formula One racing it
exactly so that's that's that's your fur
is that your first memory do you
remember getting behind the wheel oh
yeah yeah and luckily we also got the
footage from it so it's always quite
funny to look back at it no kidding yeah
so did you pretty much always wanted to
do what you are doing right now adays
yeah that's right out of sports I tried
soccer
I tried ice hockey and stuff on that but
I think I quite quickly realized that my
talent was on four wheels and stuff so I
I stopped that and basically up until I
was 16 I was in go-karting then I did
one year formula tree and and then I got
the call up to to Formula One right what
was it like that first day for you that
first win for you I guess in Spain in
2016 was also the first race I got
called up to the big team to to Red Bull
Racing at the time so yeah there was a
lot of pressure and a lot of attention
of course on that weekend but you know
the team always told me just
enjoy it just get used to the car and of
course try to score some points but yeah
luckily everything went quite well in
the start we got lucky with the two
Mercedes cars crashing out but then yeah
we just try to stay calm try to stick to
to to our strategy and yeah at the end
to win that race was was very crazy I
mean I got into that weekend expecting
nothing basically because every car is
very different and you get you have to
get used to it
sure but winning that at 18 years old as
well was it was very nice what's it like
to be on the Formula One circuit is an
18 year old well for me it was always my
dream since I was very little and of
course one goal was to get into Formula
One but there's only starts you know you
want to be successful as well and many
times people get into Formula One and
they will never win again because in for
money like 2 3 3 2 2 3 teams who can win
races right so yeah there is a
possibility get into let's say the sport
and they were yeah you love and you will
never win a race again so that first out
was that of course taken away I guess I
was kind of mentioning what it's like to
be them on the circuit driving the cars
on it's on the limit and you know the
amount of grip we have through corners
is of course amazing and it's very
difficult to to compare it to anything
else in terms of a car you know so yeah
it it was always and it still is a lot
of fun I meant lifestyle there's an 18
year old on the on the tour for me you
know I think the most important is to be
yourself and of course there's a lot of
attention around there yes but you
always have to remember where you do it
for and that is for me just try to win
races max for stopping here on the Rich
Eisen show and then what type of driver
are you when you're not racing do you
have to always Drive can you can you sit
in the passenger seat max I can yeah but
only with people I trust so I can
happily sit next to my dad for example
in the car ok my mom you better my
second you need to finish that sentence
max mom what you can you can sit you can
sit shotgun with your mom right yeah ok
yeah you want to make sure we're I don't
want to get in any trouble no no no so
my
Scizor is already a bit more tricky how
old is she she is 20 years old yeah but
she likes to go goes far go fast as well
but on the road so I have to always okay
so do you you tell her what to do is
just slow down yet hmm okay but you
normally just hop like hopping behind
the wheel yourself essentially to be
honest okay I don't mind to be the
passenger because I'm driving already
that much you know to ride the season
right once you're at home doesn't really
matter what do you do for a guilty
pleasure when you're not behind the
wheel of a car what do you do Oh what
else do you do in terms of eating life
see I just like to spend time with
family and friends because you're
traveling that much that you don't see
them that often and I don't actually
really enjoy being around them what
about it Gaming do you I do a lot of sim
racing yes so basically when I'm not
racing I'm actually still racing online
online yeah okay because that's also a
big part of form the one where we are
not allowed to go testing on on tracks
outside of the races so we have like a
very advanced simulator where we are
always practicing how the house how
close is that to the real thing I would
say 95% the 5% what is missing is the
g-forces because you can't really
simulate that in a simulator but
basically we always set up the car
already before we actually go to the
track because it's very limited running
as well there so the better you can get
prepared on that simulator it will help
you try the whole weekend max for
stopping here on the Rich Eisen show and
they just announced that there's gonna
be a race in the Netherlands next year
that's gotta mean something significant
to you right yeah since you're Dutch
yeah I mean it's gonna be very crazy but
I'm looking forward to it you know
defense they have been following me
everywhere around the world so to get a
let's say a home Grand Prix will be yeah
definitely very special forever
and other than your father who was the
driver that you wanted to emulate
growing up other than your dad did you
have one I never tuned as I never had
one I always respected everyone in terms
of their results and achievements but I
always wanted to be myself and I always
wanted to just you know be be the way I
wanted to be and I never really had
someone I looked up to right do you like
street races or track
that just announced a new street race in
Hanoi Vietnam yeah so I'm more of like a
normal Street like sorry a track track
races because the streets are fun yes
but I always feel like you can't go to
the limit because you know you have the
walls of course around you and you have
to be within the limits
well max enjoy your enjoy your your time
there in Austin Texas
I mean it's and it's it's neat to see
Formula One the the Formula one Emirates
United States Grand Prix the Circuit of
the Americas circuit of America's coming
up this weekend in Austin Texas I
appreciate you stopping by here no
problem you don't know thank you for
being here max at max 33 verse stopping
on twitter and at Micmac first stop at
one on instagram follow the be the
travels of this very well-traveled man
who's the four main you are the first
youngest of full-time races youngest to
ever lead a lap youngest to ever win a
Formula One race ya know some decent
stats now we want to go for some other
stats as well like what
winning the championship that's the most
important right damn straight max just
let him know let him know how many times
we've had people have come on here in
Wantagh scurs booths people come on here
this gets called the Rich Eisen show
bump when it happens to you right tell
everybody that okay cool you know just
go around the world and say hey you need
to stop off at the Rich Eisen show okay
we'll do that
okay forget max thanks for coming on
really appreciate you max were stopping
right here for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
Direct TV for free on be our live or
download the Rich Eisen show app